[Applause]  james missing again at the foul line  a whistle james goes down hard to the  court  caruso and payne get into it montrez  harrell  runs into campaign and coaches  leave the bench area as things become a  little bit contentious here  well it started with chris paul blocking  out lebron james  when james was up in the air on the  missed free throw  and then it was caruso and campaign  involved  in a separate issue lebrons is shaken up  he's down on one knee on the court he  landed hard he got undercut  he's holding that left shoulder  that's another look at it  and there's harold that came in late on  payne  [Applause]  there's chris paul blocking him out and  and that got called to foul there's a  loose ball foul on chris paul  then there's an altercation the  altercation is under review  you saw chris paul kind of grab lebron's  arm there  thinking that's what the foul was for  and now they're reviewing what ensued  between harold